6
24 on your wednesday morning got a lane
restriction shout out
to the logandale and overton area you
know we don't talk a whole lot about the
moapa valley so
wanted to make sure drivers on state
highway 169
know about a lane restriction that
actually started monday supposed to last
until next
friday from six in the morning until two
each afternoon
state highway 169 down to one lane at
lamar avenue
the south end of overton near the lost
city museum they're digging out and
replacing a 24 inch drainage pipe
got a flagging and pilot car that'll
escort one direction of traffic through
the work area while the other
waits a few minutes to get their turn
ndot says that they're going to take the
weekend off with no work on memorial day
as well you can review the lane
restriction and all of our stories at
eightnewsnow.com when you click traffic
then driving you crazy buckle up drive
carefully and please put down that phone
if there is something driving you crazy
email me traffic 8 8newsnow.com